activistas y políticos pro democracia de
hong kong recibieron otro golpe judicial
por parte de las autoridades nueve
fueron condenados entre 8 y 18 meses de
prisión por su participación y
coordinación de las protestas contra el
gobierno en agosto de 2019
[Música]
me siento muy relajado porque estoy
dispuesto a pagar lo que tengo que pagar
no huiré de eso porque solo estoy
haciendo algo que debemos hacer luchar
por los derechos la libertad y la
democracia para el pueblo de hong kong
entre los condenados también está el
magnate de los medios y mi light que
está en prisión desde hace meses y que
ahora ha sido acusado también de
conspiración con fuerzas extranjeras y
contra la justicia algo que le obligará
a cumplir 14 meses de prisión ahora le
esperan dos procesos más por violar la
nueva ley de seguridad nacional de los
nueve procesados se suspendió la condena
temporalmente a cuatro por su avanzada
edad algo que no ha terminado con su
profunda indignación por lo que
consideran un juicio injusto
con esto el cactus
hoy estamos muy consternados y
decepcionados por las normas y puntos de
vista que adoptó el juez para considerar
la pena de cárcel se debe respetar la
reunión pacífica racional y ordenada
en junio de 2020 beijing aprobó la ley
de seguridad nacional que castiga
severamente delitos de secesión o
confabulación estas sentencias son un
nuevo capítulo en la deriva autoritaria
de hong kong que ve como el ferro de
control de beijing en su vida política y
judicial está cada vez más presente